[موسيقى]
إذا كان زادنك محقًا في كون براغ
همزة الوصل بين أوروبا الشرقية والغربية ،
فمن الممكن أن تكون هذه الساحة هي
التقاطع ،
فما هو اسمك
[موسيقى]
بدون حواف
، أليس
كذلك؟  أعني
ذلك الرجل الملك والقديس الطيبان الذي
نظر إلى الثلج المنعش
[موسيقى]
على أي حال ، الغناء هنا
مناسب
طوال تاريخ براغ ، هذا هو
المكان الذي جاء فيه الناس
لرفع أصواتهم احتفالًا
واحتجاجًا عندما يحدث شيء
للناس  اذهب أه إلى تمثال قصر
القديس فانس ،
مارتن بالاس هو السفير التشيكي السابق
في واشنطن ، لقد أعطى جزءًا كبيرًا من
حياته
لقضية الحرية في جمهورية التشيك
في حياتك ، لقد شاهدت الأحداث الثلاثة
الرئيسية في تاريخ براغ الحديث
أنت  لقد حصلت على ربيع براغ في 68
ميثاق 77
والثورة المخملية في 68 ،
كان عمري 17 عامًا و 18 عامًا ، لذلك كان
أول لقاء مع الحرية
بالنسبة لي "  كنت مراهقًا ترى مستقبلك
ومن الواضح
أنني شعرت جيدًا بما كان يحدث
في عام 68 في ربيع
عام 1968 ،
حاولت حكومة إصلاحية في تشيكوسلوفاكيا آنذاك منح
شعبها مزيدًا من الحرية
والحريات التي تحركت السوفيتات خوفًا من
انهيار الكتلة الشيوعية.
بالدبابات وبحلول
أغسطس تم سحق ربيع براغ
[موسيقى]
أصبح المنشقون الشباب مثل مارتن
مبدعين ومفكرين في السبعينيات
، وأنشأوا الميثاق 77 ، وهو
التماس
بالغ الأهمية يستخدم قوة الكلمات وليس الأسلحة ،
كنت من أوائل الموقعين على
الميثاق 77
77 كانت منظمة العفو الدولية ستقول إن
بحثنا عن خيار عدم مغادرة
البلاد
ولكن البقاء هنا بروح حرة
سيستغرق 12 عامًا أخرى قبل
أن يتم إطلاق سراح تلك الأرواح الحرة مع
انتفاضة سلمية في عام 1989
كانت تسمى الثورة المخملية
الشيوعية
في تشيكوسلوفاكيا كانت  لا مزيد من
[تصفيق
] أتذكر أن الوضع كان جيدًا
هنا في هذه الساحة
حيث تجمعت الحشود في كل مكان هنا
لذا  حبر على أن التقديرات كانت هناك
200000 شخص
هنا وأين كنت بصحة جيدة. لقد
كنت هناك ، نعم بالتأكيد ، لذا فإن تلك
الشرفة هناك
مرة أخرى ، حيث لعب الموقعون 77
دورًا حيويًا لصديق مارتن في
الكاتب المسرحي المنشق
vaxlef havel هو ذهب  لتصبح
رئيسًا للبلاد ، هذه الساحة
هي حقًا شاهد على السلوك الجماعي
لعمليات الفحص ، وفي بعض الأحيان تكون
الأشياء المثيرة للإعجاب التي تحدث هنا
براغ هي سرد جماعي ، بر
غ شيء يجذب انتباهك لا
زال شيئًا يجب اكتشافه حتى من قبل شخ
يعيش هنا من أج
عقود من الزمن أوافق على أن
لغز براغ يكشف عن نفسه الآن
وهناك المزيد من الاكتشافات التي يجب
صنعها [موسيقى]